You probably take parts of these
characters with you in some
ways. So I just want to name
some of your characters.
Can you tell me what you've
taken from that character that I
named let's start with Killmonger.
- Oh yeah.
That was the one that stuck. I mean, yeah,
still there it's a,
I think the unapologetic
nature of doing what he felt
was right.
I think there was a,
a freeing experience to play
Erik that allowed me to dive
into parts of my personality
that I normally would downplay
or not really.
- Can you tell me what part?
- I think it's the
unapologetic nature of it.
I think there was a certain
level of not giving a fuck
that he had, that I
kind of had to tap into.
- Okay.
I like that.
I re I remember seeing that
you for a bit went to therapy
after you were done playing Killmonger
do you continue to go?
- I do.
- Okay.
I'm a big proponent of therapy.
I think everyone should
at least try it one. Yeah.
- Yeah. I think so.
You know, I think culturally
and generationally,
that is something that has been
lost within our community a
little bit or not really
like, you know, grazed over.
And I, I do think it's helpful
just to unpack a little bit,
- Just to literally talk.
- Yeah.
- Like at its base is just talking,
which I think everyone,
everyone should do.
So I'm glad that one of the
things that role led you to do
was try that. So, so that's
really important for sure.
Okay, Wallace.
- Wallace.
That's wow.
It's gotta be like a hindsight
perspective from that because
I was so young that I
wasn't really, you know,
up until like maybe mid middle
of the season, you know, it,
I tapped into more
where I really kind of like
lost myself in a role instead of
like, feeling like I was acting.
No, I think there's a little
bit like that felt, you know,
so, in hindsight,
to be able to look at the
character and be like,
what I probably took with
me from that is I guess the
vulnerability, you know, I
think he was pretty vulnerable.
- He was and he didn't want
to be in this circumstance.
- I think he, he,
he think he felt the
most out of a lot of the
characters that I've played.
He's probably the most,
you know, raw and emotional.
- Okay. Good answer.
Two more for you.
- Mmhmm.
- Oscar Grant.
- Oscar, man.
- "Fruitvale Station."
- Oscar was—yeah.
Oscar.
Ooh, that—I mean, that kinda, you know,
as a whole kicked off a
whole situ—like, movement,
I felt like.
It's more like a—
because it's a real person,
you know? It wasn't like a,
you know, some fictional
character, you know? Being able
to spend time with his family, you know,
and really get to know him
and understand who he was and,
you know,
meditating on him and asking,
you know, his spirit to kinda be
present with me during that
journey. You know,
it's a tie that's, you know,
that in the performance,
you know, you wanna,
you have to play that day out
like there's gonna be a tomorrow.
- Mm.
- And there's a certain—
- Wow, I never thought about it like that.
- You know what I'm saying?
There's a certain, like...
I don't know how this story ends.
- Yeah.
- So I think what he had to go
through in those moments is
just the frustration of
being treated like this and
the constant misunderstandings,
or the, you know,
desire to just get home.
"I just wanna go home." Like,
"I just wanna get here."
So I think that those frustrations
kinda like, you know—
something that I think was—I
ain't took it with me,
but it's something that
in hindsight again...
yeah. Mmhmm.